the man accused of shooting Boston Red
Sox legend David pop Big Papi Ortiz will
remain in jail for at least one year
while awaiting trial this morning where
T's remains in a Boston hospital where
he's recovering from a second surgery on
Friday his alleged shooter and eight
other suspects made a court appearance
in the dependant Dominican Republic all
wore bulletproof vests and helmets from
his jail cell window the suspected
gunman told reporters Ortiz was not the
intended target mullah Linga is intent
to Domingo the capital police in the
Dominican Republic have nine suspects
currently in custody but local media is
reporting that a tenth suspect turned
himself in to authorities on Friday in
connection with the David Ortiz shooting
earlier this week CBS News was the only
network to get this video after gaining
access to the suspects being transferred
from jail to a court hearing Friday in
Santa Domingo
as you can see police have them under
tight security authorities are still
looking for several others they say may
be involved in the plot including a man
wanted in connection with an attempted
murder in Pennsylvania role FIFA date
accrues the man who police say shot
Ortiz has been in custody since
Wednesday he insists the former Red Sox
star was not the intended target and he
spoke to reporters from the window of
his holding cell on Thursday
defense attorneys told us Friday night
their clients are innocent now also on
Friday we talked with dr. Jose Abel
Gonzalez he's one of the team of doctors
that treated Ortiz in the hours after
the shooting he says Ortiz was in a lot
of pain but stable when he was taken
into the operating room I saw in some
news about him saying oh please don't
let me die yeah I'm a good man but he
never said I'm a good man you know when
the police was interviewing him asking
me who had shot him he said I have no
problems I have probably no one I'm good
man and that's when they put together
two phrases separate two separate
phrases a police have not yet announced
a motive in this shooting for CBS this
morning Saturday MOA leggy
Santo Domingo Dominican Republic